[Music]
star wars visions is going to be an
exciting anime anthology series
coming to disney plus since september
japanese animation inspired a lot of the
people
at lucasfilm over the years we loved the
idea of seeing star wars expressed in
that way
each one of these studios that we
approached we found hardcore star wars
fans
they all had a story they wanted to tell
us
that
[Music]
[Music]
we were looking for something from the
heart and soul of the individual
creators
they are their visions to the lens of
star wars
there are so many genres at play
big and bold romantic and sweeping funny
comedic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we tried to have some retro vintage
feeling
we couldn't skip the asteroid influence
people loved astrovol
foreign
we feel so fortunate to be working with
these filmmakers
there's so many opportunities to reflect
japanese storytelling
in a star wars universe
star wars visions is completely
different than everything else in star
wars storytelling
audiences we'll fall in love with it
[Music]
you